welcome to this Shawn method everybody
i'm sean it's shot i'm sean to both shy
are we all show now it's chris waters
sorry i got i get that wrong every time
i do to change it yeah and he did well
you know it's a minimum of a weird start
here but uh we're gonna make up for it
with lots of terror up mmm freedom now
freedom fighting Freder ism free reader
ism uh in honor of Earth Day we decided
not to cause mayhem on fictional earth
and instead we're getting our asses to
ma's wow you made that work I didn't
know why good that's red faction
guerrilla you guys know if not I mean
check it out it's at el toque a bog
let's get into it that's what happens
when you try to host live shows and
drive actually what popped up was
there's a convoy and I'm gonna go try to
mess with that convoy so we're gonna
cause some trouble here oh I'm just
gonna fill her up real quick fine that
having me a quick test your gas stations
on Mars word and listen I just need to
get into one of these cars filled with a
charred man corpse yeah that I have
created smell a bit like Chara are you
serious no this guy nobody mainly
attacks me Oh doesn't get home run swung
with my kid a home run for it so we like
to say what happens Sean what happened
to Sean yeah I mean we are we want to
tell people about Sean um about this
terrible and
yeah it's all over what part of his body
well it starts on his face oh right you
don't think I would have remembered that
part of that like right away a little
bit and then it goes down and it's like
you want to it really okay yep and
delivered that safely to the safe house
oh no problem plus ten fist points yep
and uh we're your fist meter is we were
doing over all right let's just get
another vehicle here this is a bus it's
a party I got some I've got some
innocent bystander whoa all right how
are you not having any part they know
where tomorrow and you're going all
right well now that they're out they saw
you with that sick job and they're like
no other they're out and he's it need to
have some kind of cargos so okay yeah
here you go remote minds yeah let's fill
there you go get these in here you go
yup put these in the seats yeah you know
you got to have the seats filled
otherwise you can't justify the
expensive that's right that you don't
get if you don't get to go in the
diamond land if you're not doing a
carpool exactly all right so I think
we've got a pretty decent amount got on
there wide load we've got a we've got a
beeping cargo now we need to find is
where do they want to go yeah this is
this is a straight-up terrorism what I'm
telling I'm just gonna drive into this
like a humble outpost this is like a KFC
really tits like an mfc this is Martian
astray sees this is how you oh this is
how you demoralize the population just
so you know and three two one terrorism
someone's mad that I'm doing all this
and it's this guy oh that pot of a scent
that space plants survived except this
is what this is well that's a gun range
fight this is so great gun punch fight
just shoot just shoot him oh wow no he
he gunned punched that guy at right out
cold okay did you know I didn't want
Martha you can make people disappear
look at that witnesses he's dead he free
deliberates his soul from his body I did
that's how you maintain stealth
I don't know if that's a thing you can
do in this game think you need to check
out check the structural integrity on
this dude's house oh wait a minute Oh
Boston right here just gonna do a quick
remodeling design on a dime someone
outside of the small yeah oh gosh
there's totally do Chi I think your
stealth is blown Oh almost out the
window oh yeah let's go downstairs
particular line what I'm telling you
shooting you the shooting all throw home
the floor and die maybe this is the
problem with this gun is the pre create
holes you do you thi have no why'd you
step buddy here later oh gosh whoa it
looks really fun actually this is really
amusing ok that's what's so like see it
you can like this is great just the
wings just a joke yeah Lily doesn't it
and then ok you guys are all good but
like it will forward start to like lose
attitude control oh do that oh you
disappears entirely juiced it a little
too hard there here we go nope that's it
desi and business leave no answer area
Mars but we can still shoot down another
plane or try to get it to lose attitude
control or whatever you said which is a
smart guy thing oh man there's a red
faction crossover section of fanfic oh
yeah i lost the wing oh there goes oh no
it's not it's not only will coming in
high Oh delightful oh you're going off
the top nope oh come on keep that one on
their parachute pants come back down
here he looks like where did he go oh
yes oh and ovulation demoralize I'll say
have a look see behind us here at all
the cheats Maxwell move your dumb head
to the side oh no is your father I'm
back now on his cool we're turning on
super hammer obviously super debris is a
mystery we're gonna have to test that a
little later super toughness super
sprinting super jet pack yep why not
unlimited ammo okay cool turrets that's
just like cool tourists for cool people
I'm cool they put little sunglasses on
all the turrets it's all good free
upgrades shore maxima
al I can only assume that will make my
dower compadre over here much happier
max technology he'll turn into a cyborg
let's do that no green alert like
transparent uh yes you will be the test
case for super hammer whoa I missed it i
was looking at a thing and I don't like
this get something else when I'm trying
silver hammer for the first time you're
gonna pay attention this time okay I'm
looking I'm like no one is driving this
car Oh someone's driving its cuz it's a
space car it's a space taxi move along
sir oh my god oh that was really good as
actually around the corner how did I
even happen you could you put some kick
put some English on that shot skirted
around the corner there oh where did it
go one buck oh look he's up there did
you see it he was up on the bridge
linking us ride super debris maybe like
shoot it might be more noticeable he
like shot a rocket into the building
earth mmm-hmm some more like through the
two windows of a walkway he goes an
amount of debris but was it I don't know
oh oh yeah that was pretty soon that
scene come on that was pretty soon you
for that was completely people you
people seem alarmed this is not a no
parking sir it's no good to get this guy
boom Oh off the other car oh this guy
was thinking it's gonna drive away
safely I don't think oh wow that would
just disappear one of them's bad guy
does that you just flick it off come on
what am I bro bring on all right dump
truck
oh so good does it okay they're gonna
came to a rest my face did you see he
just really spin hahaha is there
something you feel like uh you would
love to see accomplished like you're
doing a sweet jump ok well nice it was
immediately recognizes it did it soon Oh
fantastic oh wow let's go usually go
Leroy classic one thing 01 no I can't
hit the bird good oh my goodness look
for something look at the truck we're
gonna charge get stuck in truck yah
taker no come on truck shoot the charm
to shoot the trunk and effort every time
I get it we did it on the icing on the
cake cross the finish line give up give
up here you go oh you did it you did it
that's gonna break that's gonna take us
out only a small amount of colonists
deaths I was actually over by a personal
victory this is war there's collateral
damage it says it on the screen that's
red faction guerrilla you can get this
game for like probably 75 cents now yeah
and it's really friggin fun so thanks
for watching me play Maxwell thanks for
thanks for hanging out I had a fun time
and of course if the viewers want to
tune in for more fun we've got the lobby
coming up the lobby coming up later
today showing off some battle mage some
trials and basically it's going to be
Tom mcshea trying to talk about trials
while I play trials and gloat about my
trial you should really just make him
play and talk at the same time because
it will be a train wreck and then just
let's keep abuse on him yeah and yeah
just shovel the abuse on thickly think
folks thanks for tuning in to the Shawn
method Shawn going back next week I
think he's gonna aim to play some metal
gear solid 5 ground zeroes so that's
next tuesday at 11am but of course in
just two short hours the lobby we've got
giveaways we've got games we've got
goofy mustaches on our Brotherhood of
Steel statue so come on and watch it
then thanks for watching now have a good
day have a good habit be two hours we'll
see you soon see folks
you